So far, the workflow has been easy, but sometimes, you need to scan a model from various sides to ensure the best quality.
Failure to do that may give you artifacts in the model and in the texturing, as we saw earlier with the mobile app.
You can scan the model from different sides, based on multiple photo shoots, and then use the software tools to put components together.
Here's how you can do it.
Start a new project the same way as before, by using a set of pictures shot from above the subject.
Align the images together by pressing F6.
For the hotkeys to work, ensure the focus is inside the 3D view by clicking or orbiting the 3D window.
Use the top view, 2 on the numerical keypad, and the set ground plane feature to reorient the point cloud to face north.
You can also use the reconstruction region to focus on the model.
In this method of work, you need to filter the area of interest by masking out parts that you don't need.
For that, you need a proxy model. It doesn't need to be detailed. Therefore, you can generate a preview mesh, which will be enough.
You can further clean it up using the rectangle or lasso tools and the filter selection option, as you have learned to do.
At this stage, you can generate masks that will later help in the process of merging two model parts together.
This is done through the tools menu, using the depth and mask feature.
It is of vital importance that you save those masks in the same folder where the texture maps reside.
In this case, the lion top folder.
For this process, you don't need camera depth, so you can turn that option off, but ensure the mesh masks option is enabled.
The process is relatively quick, and it creates black and white masks much faster than you would create them in an image processing app like Photoshop.
Next, we do the same with a set of images taken from below the lion's body.
Before you load those pictures, it is important to disable the current cameras in the project.
This can be done by selecting them all using CTRL-A, then disabling them using CTRL-R, and you can deselect them with CTRL-D.
Note that they all turn red in the 3D view.
Next, load the pictures from the lion bottom folder. These represent the photo shoot of the model upside down.
Repeat the process by aligning the images, adjusting the ground plane, and the reconstruction region.
Create a preview model, and clean it up by using the rectangle filter tools, and crop the upside down area, representing the actual top part of the lion model.
Again, you need to create the appropriate mask, this time saving them to the lion bottom folder.
Switch the 2D pane into 1D info pane.
Note that you now have two components, one representing the model seen from above, one from below.
You can even rename these components for more clarity.
Also, regarding the top component, make sure you select all cameras and activate them again.
This is done by using CTRL-A, CTRL-R, and CTRL-D as you did earlier.
To put the two components together, you need to reload the pictures, this time both textures and masks.
Simply drag both top and bottom folders back into RealityCapture.
Once that's done, go ahead and realign the images again.
If all goes well, another single component gets created with a one-point cloud that is the combination of the top and bottom parts.
All cameras are accounted for, from both above and below the model.
The masks ensure a clean result, which you can now generate a normal detailed mesh for,
process it, simplify it, perhaps smooth it a bit, and texture it, ending in a detailed model from very conceivable point of view.
You can finally export it as an FBX or OBJ file to your favorite DCC app or game engine.
Again, this process was fairly easy, but unfortunately it doesn't always work that efficiently.
In the next video, we look at a scenario where this process fails and how you can overcome the problem when it happens.